- But why don't we go ahead
and get started with our Bellos lecture?
This is such a highlight
for the year for the school.
It's such a part of our tradition
and we've had such wonderful
speakers over the years,
and today is certainly no exception.
We then always have, of course,
the reception afterwards,
the wizard tea.
And of course, there's history
and story to that as well.
And Sten is happy about the
tea because he's an Anglophile,
but we will have the reception following.
It's such an honor and a personal pleasure
for me to be able to introduce
to you Dr. Sten Vermund,
Dean of the School of Public Health.
Sten and I go way, way back
when I was a little student
and he was a baby faculty
back in New York City,
back in the days when the
HIV pandemic was starting.
Sten is a Yale and national resource,
trained as a pediatrician,
obviously a public health expert,
and I'm gonna say an honorary nurse.
He has always gotten the
power of public health
and nursing working together.
Since done it all, okay, so sure.
He's an infectious disease epidemiologist,
we all knew that, we've
all seen him on the media,
and he's helped Yale respond
to COVID during this pandemic,
he's a pediatrician by
training and practice.
And I think those of you
who are pediatricians
and adolescent medicine will appreciate
that clinical perspective.
He's focused on improving
care in every setting,
I'm gonna say.
He has worked in multiple
countries around the world,
always thinking about
how do we get to equity,
which, of course, is our theme
at Yale School of Nursing.
He's worked on HIV, HPV,
TB, parasitic diseases,
and of course, coronavirus,
just a handful of the pathogens
that he has brought his
bearing and his expertise to
and collaborations with so
many people around the world.
He is interested in interventional science
and he led the HIV prevention
trials network for many years,
a huge endeavor.
And so that has really moved the needle
on a lot of our HIV
prevention clinical trials
and implementation science,
which is a theme also here at Yale.
And it's always about, as
we care about as nurses,
increasing coverage, quality,
evidence, and impact of care.
He has, as I say, experience
in the real world,
in academia, and also in NIH.
And so those of you who
may have been around
during the HIV pandemic,
he was one of those
incredible bridge people
who could work with the activists,
people living with HIV, who were dying,
who were trying to make change
in how do we do science so
that people can survive.
He came up with the
first as women's cohort,
HIV women's cohort.
I think I remember you being
on stage with Jim Curran
and the activists were throwing
toilet paper at you all
and you just kept speaking,
you heard the concerns,
and change was made in
the way we do science
and what you did at NIH,
very, very incredible.
Of course, in this most recent period,
as Sten has been leading
the School of Public Health,
our sister school,
he also pivoted towards COVID-19 research,
including working with
collaborators in China
and around the world.
He worked with Yale Kamis here.
These are just some examples on mask use,
safety with schools and arts organizations
in New York City, New York,
as well as in Connecticut.
And he has really continued all that work
along with his incredible
faculty who are collaborators
of many of ours at
School of Public Health.
He's, of course, has reached
the pinnacle of achievements
in being recognized for his
science and his contribution.
He's elected member of the
National Academy of Medicine,
fellow of the American Association
for the Advancement of Science,
I'm sure missing a lot of accolades.
But really, the most important thing
is he's a genuinely kind and
smart and warm collaborator.
He champions people,
he wants everyone to be doing good work,
and he helps support us all on doing that,
including thinking about nursing
and public health partnerships.
So he's embodied that as the dean
of the School of Public Health.
He was instrumental with us as we formed
the Yale Institute for Global Health.
Remembering that the three of our schools
really launched that.
And so I didn't announce
this to you before, Sten,
but rather than getting you
a Yale bowl or Yale pen,
we're going to plant a tree for you.
- [Sten] Oh, lovely.
- And that will be our gift to you,
and thank you for speaking today,
particularly given the topic,
which is the topic of our time,
and that tree someday will grow
and shelter, and be felled,
and turned into a bowl for someone else.
But for you, it'll be the tree.
Thank you, Sten.
- Thank you.
Thank you, Ann. Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
Well, that was very kind, very generous,
and I'm really thrilled to be here.
I came shortly after my arrival
in 2017 over to the school,
marveled at your space, salivated,
and was really impressed
with what you were doing
in the school.
That was the time you were
doing your simulation labs,
you were building them,
and there was just so much
vibrancy and excitement
in the school, and there
still is to this day.
So I'm bringing a relatively
familiar topic to you,
so I hope I can give it some novelty
and a little bit of perspective.
So what we're going to
try to do is take a look
at the latest data I could find,
and just remind you that
prior climatologic predictions
from green house gas release
have actually understated true effects.
This is if we've learned
anything in the last 12 months,
it's that all of these dire predictions,
it's the upper 95% confidence
interval that we're tracking,
not the middle, certainly not the low.
So we'll review a few
climatological highlights,
discuss mitigation efforts,
implications for human health,
for example, strategies for
adaptation to planetary warming,
relevance for loss of
habitat, species diversity,
comment on human and population growth,
and will end with a comment
about nursing as a vital element
for climate change adaptation.
Now it took me, I'm not
quite the guru in this topic,
but Ann is, and I would model my use
of the word mitigation and adaptation.
I'm gonna put it out there
just because I learned it.
Now, if I'm a carbon capture engineer,
or if I'm somebody working
on policy to guide us
to set our thermostats properly,
or to massively improve solar power,
or improve the efficiency of machinery
so it uses less energy,
then I'm mitigating climate change.
But if I'm just a pediatrician
with a background in infectious
disease epidemiology,
and I'm looking at island
nations that are being inundated,
or I'm looking at malaria
zones that are expanding
and I'm trying to help cope
with that, that's adaptation.
So what we really want
is we want mitigation,
but guess what?
We, nurses, public health
professionals, docs,
and health providers have
to worry about adaptation,
'cause that's our space,
that's the space where we think
we can actually make a difference.
So let me make sure I
can get this to work.
And here you've seen
this before, many of you.
From 1880 to 2021, the more
yellow and the more red,
the greater the deviance
from historic norms.
And take a look at the poles,
how much red pops up at the poles.
And I guess we're at 1990
now and we're coming to 2000
and 2010 and 2021.
Oops, didn't mean to show it twice.
Okay, so the annual mean
surface temperature anomaly
is what the meteorologist refer to
when they're doing these historic
temperature gradient comparisons.
And the past eight years
have been the warmest
in recorded history
as per the World
Meteorological Organization,
and as per everybody else.
No matter who is analyzing this,
they all say the same thing
even with different methods.
The last eight years have been
modern history's warmest eight years.
There are record levels of heat-trapping
atmospheric greenhouse gases.
The global temperature about 1.1 degrees
higher than historic norms.
And you know that we're
trying with climate change
to keep it to under 1.5
and we're not gonna get there actually,
but we need to work today to
make sure we keep it under two.
So this is the seventh consecutive year
where global temperature
has been more than one degree celsius
above pre-industrial levels.
And you know the consequences are massive,
loss of sea ice and ice
sheet mass, sea level rise.
We've got longer, more intense heat waves
and major habitat changes affecting humans
and animals and plants alike.
And I'm just straining to see.
So the upper map is global
temperature trends, 1901 to 2017.
And the lower map is 1988 to 2017.
So just to give you a sense
of the comparative analysis.
And the greenhouse gas trends
are unremittingly grim,
up, up, up.
So here's another fancy,
Sten can barely cope video.
Okay, so now we start in 2002
and we take a look at the
Greenland ice mass loss
over about a 19-year period,
and will be coming up to 2020.
And this is Greenland ice loss
and meters equivalent relative to 2002.
And when we're measuring here,
this Y axis is mass loss in gigatons.
Now I personally have
no concept of a gigaton
other than it's a heck of a lot of ice.
That's my technical
interpretation of a gigaton.
It's a massive amount of ice.
And one more time, and
this is Antarctic ice mass,
that was Greenland,
now we have Antarctica,
and this is from 2002 to 2019.
And taking another look at 150 gigatons
of lost ice mass per year.
What happens is that
these glacial features
are almost like the stopper on a bottle.
And when you take the
stopper off by melting,
and you might have the separation
of a distal part of the glacier,
the rest of the glacier
starts to move even faster.
You've taken that bottle
off or that bottle top off,
so that's what we're facing.
And you may be aware
that we had about two,
was it two, three years ago, Ann?
The calving of a huge
component of Antarctica,
the size of the state of Rhode Island.
Now that did not do much
for global sea level rise,
because it was already
essentially floating,
but it's separated now
and now it will melt,
and then it will contribute.
And we're running into massive shifts
that the climatologists
really can't even believe.
Now, that's just Mount Kilimanjaro,
the tallest mountain in Africa.
If you're my age, you actually
read Hemingway as a kid,
these short stories, and
then you saw the movie
with Gregory Peck, and Susan
Hayward, and Ava Gardner,
"The Snows of Kilimanjaro."
There are no more snows on Kilimanjaro.
So you look at 1912, you
look at 1970, 2000, and 2007,
and this is schematically
represented over to the right.
And the snow mass on
the top of Kilimanjaro
is relatively trivial.
As a consequence in the
warming of the entire region,
this used to be the part of Kenya
where the colonials would
go to a avoid malaria
in the hot season.
Well, now you have malaria all the way up,
halfway up Kilimanjaro,
you can get malaria,
and that's because of expanded
vector-breeding opportunities
because it's warmer and moisture.
There's also been a lot of deforestation.
And so you throw that in
and you have a lot of
trouble in this region.
Now, the most terrifying
of all the slides,
we'll get to the optimistic slides later,
that's what we're gonna all do about this.
But the most terrifying slide is this one,
the thermohaline circulation,
particularly in the Atlantic current,
the so-called meridional
overturning circulation
or the MOC.
Now these are the giant
rivers within the oceans,
if you wanna look at it that way.
So deep down, you have
cold water currents,
they rise as they come into the tropics,
and then they return
as warm water currents.
The most famous of which
is the Gulf Stream.
So if you look at the Gulf Stream up here,
take a look at just how far north,
I think I have a pointer, I can't see it.
Anyway, you know where Norway is,
where my parents came from, and Iceland,
and take a look at how far north that is.
That's Greenland, that's
Siberia, that's Northern Canada.
Now why can people live
in Iceland and Norway?
It's all about the Gulf Stream.
That's why those are habitable countries.
They're way too far north to be habitable
in a productive way.
So what's happened is for the first time
in a recorded history,
we've measured the
slowing of these currents
and nobody on Planet Earth has a clue
as to what that might mean.
We do know that there
has systematic warming
and bleaching of reefs because of warming,
so that corals are adapted
to slightly cooler water,
you warm it up, they die.
And it's also true that we've seen
massive displacements of fish populations
as they seek cooler waters closer
to their millennially
adapted physiologies.
So this could be the most
important consequence
of global climate change
if we actually see the
substantial disruption
of these currents because
we really don't know
how this could disrupt the
ecosystems of the globe.
So here are the health issues,
direct effects of heat.
We have hotter and drier summers
and we can have heat-related deaths.
We have warmer and wet winters
with the consequence of loss
of polar and glacial ice.
We have increased extreme weather events,
we have property and crop loss,
and we have loss of reef ecosystems,
which disrupts fish yield.
So you can see the direct
effects on our food chain
and especially among the
elderly and the very young
who are much more susceptible
to things like heatstroke.
And you may recall in Europe,
it was about 15 years ago,
there was a massive
atypical European heat wave.
And it's estimated that
20,000 or so elderly in Europe
whose air conditioners were not working
or who didn't have air conditioners,
and they called the air
conditioning supply company,
and nobody came because
they were overwhelmed
with other calls
and they essentially
cooked in their apartments.
And that has happened a
lesser degree in the US,
but it's the kind of thing
that we can anticipate.
So are we, as nurses, in this case,
maybe not pediatrician, but for the kids.
Are we as geriatricians,
are we going to start taking seriously
how well networked our elderly are
in time of stress and emergency?
Are we going to actually have
plans to cope with heat waves
and the inevitability that
one in 20 air conditioners
gonna break down during this period
and isn't gonna be fixed
because the companies are overwhelmed?
Are we going to plan for this?
These are the sorts of adaptation issues
that we have to think about.
And there are plenty
of direct heat effects
that we're going to have to worry about.
Perhaps, the most dramatic example
of a direct heat effect
is desertification.
So the Sahara Desert is moving south
in the Sahel region of Africa,
at least 100 kilometers per year,
and that is displacing
the grazers and farmers
who have lived in these
Sahel border regions
with the desert.
And this is the kind of
phenomenon you'll see
when you go there.
People having abandoned
their dying animals
and having to migrate, tremendous stress,
and if the vegetation animals
aren't going to survive,
the people have to move.
Now we have this
climatologic displacement,
climate refugees that I just alluded to
with my desertification slide,
and extreme weather events,
which also are going to face
resulting in internally displaced people,
and sometimes even
refugees across borders.
That's the kind of definition.
If you cross borders, you're a refugee.
If you're displaced
within your own country,
you're an internally displaced person,
just for the vocabulary.
Now I find this website to be fascinating,
the Alliance of Small Island States.
This is 35 countries and five territories,
including all of ours.
Members of the territories
of this organization
include Puerto Rico,
American Virgin Islands,
and Northern Marianas Islands,
American Samoa, and Guam.
Those are the five territories
in the United States,
and they're all members of this.
So what they are worried
about is their existence.
Now take a look at what
two different modelers
using two different
strategies did in modeling
what will happen with one
meter ocean rise in Florida
in the next 30 years, and
next 50 years, I think it is.
And this is one modeler, and
the ecological devastation
that the entire Everglades
are going to be swamped
with salt water, it can't be understated.
I mean, that'll be a dead zone.
And then some very valuable real estate,
including all of the Kennedy Space Center
will be underwater.
And this modeler, the one to the right
is much more pessimistic,
much greater saturation of seawater
into the State of Florida.
Now we will spend billions
and billions and billions
and hundreds maybe of billions of dollars
to build sea walls and mitigate this.
So when we say we can't afford
to tackle climate change,
that's because people are thinking
in two, three-year economic windows.
They're not thinking in 20,
30-year economic windows.
Now, as temperatures rise,
more and more water vapor
evaporates into the atmosphere,
that is fuel for storms, as any
climatologist will tell you,
and the more heat and
water in the atmosphere
with warmer ocean surface temperatures
increases storm wind speeds,
and their analogous
temperature phenomena on land,
which increase the strength of tornadoes.
So we can expect greenhouse gas emissions
and global warming to result
in more extreme weather events
and we've already seen it.
Now, keep in mind too,
that snow reflects heat,
it's white, reflects,
whereas rock absorbs it.
Dark absorbs it, absorbs it.
You learned that in grade school.
And with fresh water snow
pack and glacier losses,
loss of snow pack, loss
of glaciers, earlier rain,
rain on snow, we are
going to see new cycles
of floods and then droughts.
And I'll circle back to
that in a few slides.
And the costs of these events are vast.
There are 15 Atlantic current hurricanes
that have cost at least
$10 billion each of damage.
And the king and queen of these hurricanes
were Katrina in New Orleans
and Harvey in Houston.
Each of which resulted in
$125 billion worth of damage.
And it just is a miracle to
me that our political leaders
argue that we can't afford to mitigate
and adapt to climate change
when we're incurring these kinds of costs,
and we will be incurring vast new costs
for dubious technologies like seawalls,
that may or may not work.
Now, vector-borne diseases,
this is sort of more my field.
And in our school, we do a
lot of work in this space,
and that's a long list.
And I hate lecturers who give
you slides with long lists,
but I couldn't resist.
Just to let you know
that you've got
mosquito-related infections,
'cause mosquitoes, remember,
if the mosquito is here and I'm malarious,
it has to bite me,
then it has to live the sexual life course
of the malaria parasite,
which is now the male and
female are finding themselves,
and the sporozoites are gonna mature
after the oocysts mature in the midgut.
That takes eight to 12 days
depending upon the species.
So the mosquito is not gonna infect Ann
if it doesn't live eight to 12 days.
But if we help it live eight to 12 days
by being warmer and moisture,
then a greater proportion of
all the malarious mosquitoes
will survive to infect others.
So you can see how that
could have radical rise
in malarial incidents.
Similarly, arboviruses and many
other vector-related infections
in which black flies like
warm moist environments,
so do snails, so do rodents,
so do tsetse flies and
reduviidae bugs, so do ticks,
and you can even have water that is warmer
for a longer period of time
that might harbor cholera
and other waterborne disease
for a longer time, so that's the story.
And here's is Zimbabwe where 10 years ago,
those were the highlands, which
were largely malaria-free,
and 30 years from now,
there will be no malaria-free
zones of the nation.
They will all be hyperendemic
or even holoendemic for malaria.
Holoendemic being one
notch even more intense
in terms of transmission
than hyperendemic.
Then we have population
pressures and shrinking land
and water assets that
also includes fish assets.
Now this slide comes from Lake Victoria,
and you recall that that's a lake
that borders Uganda, Kenya, and Tanzania.
And if you look at 1960
and take a look at the population density,
and then you go all the
way forward to 2015,
you'll see massive population growth
and pressures on the lake.
And the fisher folk who
live around Lake Victoria
will make their living
supplying protein-rich fish
to the population, they
are now harvesting smaller
and smaller and smaller fish.
It's exactly what happened
in the Grand Banks off of Newfoundland,
the richest cod fishing
zones in the entire world
that were fished out about 30 years ago
and have never rebounded,
the codfish have never
rebounded the Grand Banks,
which was mind-boggling to those of us
who remember that from our childhood,
where that was the
teeming source of codfish,
and now you don't fish for
cod in the Grand Banks,
'cause there's no more cod.
And the prospect of overfishing,
overgrazing on the land,
deforestation, farmland pressures
is almost certainly going to result
in hunger and climate refugees
in this very intensively
populated part of the world.
And guess what?
We're repeating this
story in lake after lake
after lake ecosystem all around the world
where population pressures
are severely affecting.
Here's the Aral Sea and
the historic Aral Sea
is what all the blue represents.
And the current is just this dark blue.
And you can see how the
historic was this vast area,
and the current is like this.
That gentleman is standing
where the sea used to lap,
where the sea used to reach.
And there's a Navy worth of vessels
that are completely abandoned,
because not only is there
much less water in Aral Sea,
but it's now saline water
for all practical purposes,
Great Salt Lake, kind of thing.
And there are no fish in the
Aral Sea that can be harvested.
This is from crop growing
in which the rivers
were diverted to feed the very
water-thirsty cotton plants
and extensive use of
pesticides and fertilizers,
most of which end up up
in the Aral Sea eventually
poisoning the fish.
Now the exact same phenomenon
is happening in Lake Chad,
which is a fraction of its
size, Chad, Niger, Nigeria.
It's estimated to be about half the size
that it has been historically.
And those of you who have
some California roots,
I went to high school and
college in California.
The Mono Lake used to be this vibrant,
large lake in Northern
California, it's a wasteland now,
because all that water was
used for urban water supplies,
and did not have adequate
restoration capacity.
Now you can't mention
water, lakes, grazing
without mentioning forests,
because if you go to 10,000
years ago or 5,000 years ago,
more than half the habitable planet.
So 77% of the globe was habitable.
So get rid of Antarctica
and the Arctic, et cetera,
and get rid of the highest
mountains of the Himalayas
and look at the rest, that was 77%.
So this represents 100% of the 77%
of which more than half was forest.
Even in 1700, more than half was forest.
It fell below half by the
time we had a billion people
on Earth in 1900,
and you had 8% being used for
crops and 16% for grazing.
And that has doubled in a
little more than 100 years.
So now we're using 15% for
crops and 31% for grazing land.
And I don't know if this surprises you,
but it sure surprised me.
If you'd given me a quiz and said,
get this answer right or I'm
confiscating your favorite pet.
I would've bet on grazing, on crop land,
being more than grazing land,
but grazing land is more than double.
And a lot of deforestation is happening
to accommodate our thirst for meat,
our hunger for meat would
be a better term. (laughs)
And that is kind of what we're looking at
just in a 48-hour period.
Those are the active fires
going on in Latin America.
And you can see how the Amazon
is deforested and then burned
to prepare it for grazing and for crops.
Now I have offended people
in audiences with this slide,
it's from the UN, and I
wanna explain it clearly.
So the United Nations estimates
that 222 million women
who live in low and
middle income countries
would like to have
access to contraception,
but they do not have access.
That's what we mean by unmet
need for contraception.
We're not talking about coercing anybody,
we're not even talking
about convincing anybody.
This is when you ask,
would you like to space your children
and not have a child every year?
Would you like to control the fertility
within your family structure?
And they say yes.
And do you have access to contraception
so you can control your fertility?
They say no.
Would you like it? Yes, that's unmet need.
If we could meet that unmet need,
that would handle demand in 50 million
of persons under the age of 25.
14 million of them are
under the age of 20,
and 162 million of them
are in the world's poorest countries,
where you have the least capacity
to have a family of 10 or 12.
That would prevent 63
million unwanted pregnancies,
and it would prevent 19
million unsafe abortions.
And it would also save 82,000
mothers' lives directly.
So education and sustainable
economic empowerment,
especially for girls and women does a lot
to advance control of fertility.
We've seen that in study
after study internationally.
There are exceptions where, for example,
you have very strong pro-natal sentiments,
Orthodox religions, for
example, of various sorts,
where there's a very strong desire
to have very large families.
So then the education and
economic empowerment formula
doesn't quite work.
But in every other environment,
it works very well.
So there's a vast unmet need.
And keep in mind that
when I was born in 1954,
there were 2.7 billion people on Earth,
and now there are 7.9
billion people on Earth.
And it took us a 100 years
to double the population previously,
and it's taken us half of 100 years
to increase it almost threefold.
So we either take global
population control seriously,
or we don't.
We don't take it seriously,
then you're gonna have a
lot of underfed children
in families that are
not able to support six,
seven, eight, nine, 10 children,
and didn't want that number of children.
There's a lot of individual
and community tragedy,
but there's also an existential
threat to Planet Earth,
because reasonable people have argued
that 7.9 billion people is too many people
for a good quality of
life for people on Earth.
And we can do a lot if all
we do is meet unmet need.
So I dwelled on this slide
to make sure you understand
my point of view.
I am not looking to coerce anybody,
no one child policy, no nothing.
Just meet the need of women
who want contraception,
meet that need, and we will do a lot
to turn to the right direction.
So let's take a look at events
in the past two years, 2020, 2021.
We had Australian and
Western USA wildfires
that were the worst in the history
of those two countries by far,
the largest, the most intense.
We had tremendous challenges
in smoke exposure and poor air quality,
and we had a lot of mental health impacts.
People who lost everything,
lost their homes,
some people lost lives of loved ones,
firefighters were lost, on and on.
I've already mentioned
the temperature records
of the past eight years
being the hottest ever,
but they're also local venue
hottest day ever records
that have been broken in
historic sweep from Siberia,
all the way to Arizona and Florida,
places that had broke their records
by five degrees Fahrenheit,
10 degrees Fahrenheit.
There was one place in Siberia
that broke the record by
40 degrees Fahrenheit.
And 2020 and 2016 were the hottest years
in recorded history,
although 2020 isn't that
different from 2021.
In fact, they were judged to
be virtually indistinguishable.
COVID had an interesting result,
which was a favorable impact
on greenhouse gas emissions
because there was less driving,
there was less industry, and the like.
But the impact on food supply
chains were very complex.
Some places were not severely impacted,
other places were severely impacted.
So I can't exactly cheer for
COVID having done as much good
because a lot of these are now rebounding
to his historic levels of
greenhouse gas emissions.
Finally, we'll talk about evolving drought
and flood cycles and famine risk.
So this is a map where
they are showing the size
of glacial regions in the Himalaya.
And the loss in glacial
size is represented
by the red color.
If it's white color, no change,
and if it's blue, a
little bit of addition,
so overwhelmingly loss,
especially in the glaciers
that are closest to population,
areas that are feeding the Indus River,
the Brahmaputra, Ganges River,
and the Mekong River deltas.
Now 1.5 billion people
live in these deltas.
And what is now happening is early,
three-week shorter snow pack,
and earlier melting,
and earlier springtime flooding,
and later summer drought.
So it's not actually a
net decline or increase
in total precipitation.
It's more rain, less snow,
and earlier snow pack
melt and glacial melt
with greater volumes in
the rivers early in season,
and then drought volumes
later in the season.
And none of this is good news.
None of this suggests that
we are going to have farmers
and villagers better off
with these conditions
than they've been historically.
They're going to be worse off
with early floods, late droughts.
Here is Borneo over
about a 19-year period.
And if it's green, it means forest,
and if it's orange, it means no forest.
And to the right, you
have Northeast Brazil.
If it's blue green, it's forest loss,
and if it's red, there's forest,
different kind of infrared photography.
And to the left, it's
because of deforestation
and population pressures, grazing,
and a little bit of oil exploration,
not a little bit, in
certain areas, a lot of it,
and to the right, it's all mining.
Of course, I could have
taken a different picture
from Brazil in the Amazon.
It would've been due to deforestation.
So there is a lot going on in our world
that is not favorable.
Now the good news.
With research, policy, education, action,
this is both feasible and necessary.
We can confront global climate
change at the same time,
take a look at issues
of loss of biodiversity
on our planet and human overpopulation.
So efficient transportation
looms very large.
We are burning fossil fuels
when we could be using solar power.
So three years ago, my wife
and I went solar in our house,
cost us $33,000.
We got about 10,000 back
from our taxes and the feds,
and we got about 3,000
back from the state,
so that was a net of $20,000.
We pay virtually no, just the hookup fee,
and we bought an electric car,
so our electric car is
powered by our solar panels.
And are we gonna change the
history of Planet Earth?
By no means, but I'm hoping
we might influence our neighbors.
And I'm hoping you might do the same
and might influence your neighbors.
In other words, there has to
be some level of tipping point
where some of us get ahead of the curve
and take a risk on new technology,
'cause it's not new anymore.
Solar panels prices have plummeted,
and it really is very favorable
if your home happens
to be properly suited.
Some people live in the
middle of the forest
and short of cutting down a
bunch of trees, it won't work.
But many of us have some solar
exposure and we can go solar.
So that's at the micro level,
but at the macro level,
you can do what Bishop's farms.
How many of you have had a pie
from Bishop's out in Guilford?
They are completely carbon neutral.
That's not because they're
buying car carbon credits,
they've become carbon neutral
because they've deployed a
number of their orchards,
and they have turned
them into solar farms.
So all of the energy utilization of,
yeah, I think they have some gas vehicles,
but they're selling enough,
they're installing enough energy,
solar energy into the
grid to balance that.
We can do so much more here at Yale.
My building, the LEPH
building, many of you know,
60 colleges is, out of
150 buildings on campus
that had energy audits was the
15th least energy efficient.
I'm ashamed to walk into that
building every single day.
And they've done some mitigation,
remediation, I should say,
and I think were not quite that bad,
but they haven't done
the definitive things.
And we can power electric
cars, buses, trains.
There's nothing stopping us,
now we have the technology.
Energy conservation,
the notion of having it
at 68 in the winter and 72 in the summer
is not that big a sacrifice,
but people don't do it.
And it just enrages me when
I go into a public space
in the summer, and I'm
sorry, I forgot my sweater,
'cause we just keep it, the
Europeans think we're nuts
because they don't do that.
And you go into a hotel in Europe
in the middle of the winter
and you better have a sweater
'cause it's a little chilly.
And you go in the summer, it's
gonna be a little bit warmer
maybe than you're used to,
but we just have to adapt.
We're just wasting energy.
We have double the energy utilization,
the average American than
the average European.
We have automatic shut
offs, we have LEED buildings
that we ought to be promulgating.
We have many other
sustainable energy sources
and I put nuclear in yellow
just to stimulate conversation later.
And economic incentives, cap
and trade, carbon credits,
tax credits, and the whole
ocean of sustainable land use
and population stabilization.
Do we really have to eat
as much meat as we do?
Do we really have to as much
grazing land as we have?
Couldn't we take advantage of the fact
that it takes 10 kilos of plant protein
to grow one kilo of meat protein?
Couldn't we eat some of
that plant protein instead?
The answer is of course.
Now political change and
commitment is essential
and we need better leadership.
There was a moratorium and
fossil fuel exploration
with massive shift
alternative energy sources.
How many of you noticed
the announcement last week
from the Biden administration?
Opening up hundreds of
thousands of acres of land
for oil exploration again.
And, that I call the
Ukraine policy set-back.
And I put that in yellow 'cause
that might be of interest
to us to discuss in a moment.
Commitment to conservation
with policy shifts,
as I mentioned.
We've had tremendous success
changing tobacco attitudes,
changing drinking under
the influence attitudes.
You don't smoke in airplanes anymore,
you don't smoke in buildings anymore.
And we've seen, and we have
much higher tobacco taxes
and we've seen tobacco use drop.
We can create, we can work
with our economist friends,
and we can incentives to make
it more expensive for you
to pollute and less expensive
for you not to pollute.
And if we don't do it, we're in trouble.
We need aggressive
preservation of wild places
to enhance biodiversity
and mitigate CO2 release,
reforestation, control
pesticide use and pollution.
And there's a lot of
good advice coming out
of the Glasgow conference.
I'm proud to say Yale, colleague of ours,
Secretary Kerry, is spearheading this now
as the international climate change
at the cabinet level, I might add,
and we couldn't ask for a better voice.
Now the emergency response and planning,
this is something that's
in our bailiwick as nurses,
as planners, public health folks.
We need to anticipate heat waves,
drought and extreme weather
modeling, forecasting,
relocation of persons doing
the flooding and storm.
We can plan for the unknown knowns.
We know it's gonna happen,
we don't know when,
but we can plan for it
so that when it happens,
we are ready.
What about if we had taken
the advice of the CDC in 2017
when they came out with updates
of their pandemic
influenza prevention plans?
Which was like a roadmap
what we should be doing
to get ready for COVID, we
just didn't know it was COVID.
It was largely ignored and
largely sat on a shelf,
and then we had COVID
and we weren't ready.
We knew what to do, we just weren't ready.
Incentivize and improve the
appeal of vegetable-based diets.
The head of Yale hospitality
here is incredibly creative.
He and his experts have lopped off
half of the meat consumption
of Yale undergraduates
over the last five years with nary a peep
through creative use of
vegetables, creative menus,
and strategies for making foods appealing
that are largely plant-driven.
If he can do it, we can
do it in our households
and we can do it in our
institutional settings.
And control of air and water
pollution is a no-brainer.
Vector control, bednets,
community engagement.
That's a big one 'cause
we've got to educate.
Water and hygiene innovation,
the old drip technologies
that the Israelis taught us 60 years ago
in the kibbutzes, protect the environment,
retain ecological diversity,
and the contraception agenda.
So the kids know we've gotta
do something, Greta Thunberg.
The South Africans have
faced this in a big way.
There's my favorite Bishop's Orchard,
and here are divestment protestors saying,
"Yeah, Yale with your
$44 billion endowment,
do you really have to be
owning fossil fuel companies?
Really? Can't you be a
role model for others?"
And this I wanna end with,
habitat loss is a major
threat to biodiversity.
I've kind of gone over my time, I think.
Am I right? I'm okay?
Okay, well, that's a miracle.
So habitat degradation, exploitation,
invasive species,
pollution, climate change.
Those are what are
affecting fish, mammals,
reptiles, and amphibians, and birds now,
and you can just expect
the climate change blue
to grow and grow and grow.
So this is kind of 10 years ago
and it's just gonna get worse
on the climate change side.
So we've already had tremendous threats
to habitats and biodiversity.
It's estimated we've
lost three billion birds
in North America in recent years.
And insect populations
have plummeted as well.
And you might say, "Well, that's
great. Well, great by me."
I don't like bugs, but that's
what the amphibians eat,
that's what the birds eat.
That's a vital part of our food chain,
and why are we losing insects?
What are we doing to the planet
that's resulting in the loss of insects?
That's an even more compelling issue.
So we are very focused on education.
I was so proud when the very first year
that we launched our climate change
and health certificate
program, we had three nurses.
They were all from Mass General.
And I asked them when
I had an opportunity.
Why are you taking this course?
They said, "Well, we are the three people
who care the most about climate change
in the nursing school at Harvard.
We all happen to be at Mass General,
we're all helping each other.
We're going to take your curriculum
and we're going to work it
into the nursing curriculum
of Harvard University."
And I just was the happiest man
because to me that was the whole point
of the climate change certificate.
And now we have it as a MOOC, Mass Online,
something, what is MOOC stand for?
Course, somebody knows, Mass
Online something course,
Open Course, open, Mass
Online Open Course.
And I can't remember if it's
free or if it's 49 bucks,
but it's incredibly cheap
and that's pretty much everything here
without the love and attention.
And we have our new climate change
and health concentration in our MPH.
We have an emphasis in
our executive online MPH.
So we even have people who
live in Milford and Madison
who are taking this
just 'cause it's so much easier
when they're working professionals.
Then we got people in California,
and Louisiana, and elsewhere.
And then we're doing K-12 outreach
for education in our schools.
A lot of community outreach
talks to all sorts of audiences.
I gave a talk to the
Connecticut arborists,
the people who chopped down
trees and replant them.
And somebody had heard me talk
and they asked me to give a talk,
so I slept up to West Harvard
and met the arborists.
Anybody else who wants to hear about this?
Now you happen to be in
an epicenter of expertise
right here in this building.
You can read about it on your own website.
And you spearheaded this Graduate Forum
and Global Youth Summit just last year.
Dean Curth co-chairs the
Sustainability Committee.
She's one of three deans on that committee
and she's a leader, Yale and
nationwide in this space.
And I'm not kidding.
She literally educated the
president of our university,
and that's why planetary health
is one of our major priorities.
It was deemed a major priority
by Scott Strobel's old science committee,
but it was not well-packaged,
it was not well-presented,
and Ann fixed all of that
almost single handedly.
And then Associate Dean Nelson
spearheads Planetary Health
in its global context
being the associate dean for global health
and planetary health, something like that.
I wanted to mention Jodi Sherman
and the work she's doing
on Healthcare Environmental
Sustainability.
Those of you who are deeply engaged
in hospital care, which
is a number of you.
This is very much focused on the fact
that if the hospitals and
healthcare environments
of the world were a country,
they would be the 11th largest
greenhouse gas emitter.
So the healthcare industry itself
is one of the worst offenders
in terms of greenhouse gas emission,
and that's because we use
it once and throw it away.
That's because we have
our anesthetic gases,
which we're pumping and
only 3% is metabolized,
and 97% is re-released,
and on and on and on,
all sorts of reasons.
You wanna get active, call Jodi.
She is a force of nature
and doing very fine work
out of the School of Public Health
in the medical school and
working also with Ann.
And many other nursing resources.
Yesterday or day before,
I did a PubMed search,
I found 775, just for
climate change and nursing,
that's all I did, simplest
search in the world,
and nearly half of them were
from the last three years.
And I found a couple from Ann
in the Journal of Nursing
Scholarship, two of them.
And I also found this collaboration
of the Alliance of Nurses
for Healthy Environments
and it's Nurses Climate Challenge.
I accidentally put an apostrophe.
They don't have an apostrophe.
Nurses Climate Challenge Initiative,
collaborating with Health Without Harm,
and these are a couple of resources there.
So nurses are at the forefront
of the demand that we do
something at about this,
and I think public health people are too.
I'd like to get our
medical schools on board,
I'd like to get our universities on board,
and we can actually make a difference.
So thank you for your attention.
A few sites from our site
and looking forward to tea.
(audience applauding)
So who wants to talk about
Ukraine, or nuclear power,
or any other topic?
Any questions or comments, please?
Yes?
- [Audience Member] I wanna
know about this nuclear power.
- Okay, so I'm an old-fashioned guy
and I saw the China Syndrome
and I lived through Three
Mile Island and Chernobyl.
And if you asked me,
do I wanna live next to
a nuclear power plant?
I'd say, "No, thank you."
On the other hand, nuclear
power is very benign
from a greenhouse gas
emissions point of view.
You produce a vast amount of energy
with no greenhouse gas emissions.
So I'm not saying that the process
doesn't have some
greenhouse gas emissions,
but it's tiny, tiny fraction.
And you generate vast amounts of energy.
One massive problem, well, two problems.
One is safety, Three Mile
Island, Chernobyl, Fukushima.
But the other is, where do you
put the spent nuclear fuel,
which still is radioactive
for the next 30,000 years or whatever?
And we thought we had a
plan for Yucca Mountain,
which was vetted for 50 years
as a highly stable mountain,
seismically inactive,
a natural depth, and a place
that you literally could store.
And the Nevada senators
and congresspersons
were too powerful, and they put a kibosh,
and President Obama abandoned
the Yucca Mountain plan.
And now we're storing
it all over the place.
San Onofre in California,
not far from where I went to high school,
is storing all of their nuclear
waste right there on site,
and they've walled it
off and they've got it.
But it's sitting there
near the Pacific Ocean,
and all these experts are saying,
"Oh, it can stand the big
one, the the big quake."
I don't believe that for a second.
So they're storing it there
'cause they have nowhere to take it.
So if we were serious about nuclear,
we would have to get
very serious about issues
like if you're gonna put this near water
because you have to have the cooling,
so you have to put these near water
or you have to have water available,
then you better think about a tsunami,
and you better think about the
big earthquake in California.
You better think about all
of the safety considerations.
So we need a coherent safety approach
and we need a coherent
nuclear disposal approach.
But I have changed my mind over the years.
I think that the urgency of
the global warming crisis
has to make us rethink nuclear.
Now I'd much prefer that we
reduce our energy consumption,
I'd much prefer for that
we go solar and electric,
I'd much prefer many other things,
but I think we're gonna need nuclear too.
Now the French have shown
it can be done safely.
The French have had the highest proportion
of nuclear power in their grid
of any country in the Western world,
or I think any country anywhere,
and they have ever had a nuclear accident.
But their nuclear waste
storage is still suboptimal.
So that's what I personally
think about nuclear.
Yes, please.
- [Audience Member] You
talked a little bit earlier
about the attitude of short-term planning
versus long term planning.
And I wondered if you had any examples
of whether that be
domestically or abroad people
who are doing a good job of saying like,
okay, we need to look at the 40-year plan,
the 50-year plan, as opposed
to the four-year political
elected office term
and how to kind of bring that together.
Is anybody doing a good job with that
that we could model?
- Well, I might pluck out the Danes.
So the Danes figured there
was a big problem 30 years ago
and they invested massively
in a resource that they have,
a lot of other people don't have,
which is known as the North Sea wind.
And I think the second
largest wind farm in the world
is off the coast of
Denmark, and it's in a part
where it's out literally in the North Sea,
not where they're in
intense bird populations,
and they figured out the technology
of how to seat the wind farm into the sea
and how to harvest the energy
by bringing it subterranean back to land.
And I wish I could remember the proportion
of all the energy grid in
Denmark that's from wind,
but it's a really high
number, like 30% or something.
And this is a test of concept.
They proved it could be done.
I have been to Xinjiang province,
the province with a
majority Uyghur population
in Northeast China.
Now there is tremendous
political disruption,
and discrimination, and harm
being done to the Uyghurs
in that part of China.
But before that, I had a project there
and I went through the largest wind tunnel
and this was between two mountain chains.
They took advantage of the natural wind
that was feeding this big
valley and they built wind farm
that was further than the eye could see,
all with modern wind technology.
So there's a lot that
can be done with wind.
Solar technology has improved massively,
and we have some examples
in our own country
of highly successful solar strategies.
But I think where I'm most disturbed
is when I go visit my younger
son who lives in Orlando,
and I just see so few solar panels.
And this is like, you think about Florida,
you think about Arizona, and then think
about Chad and Niger, and Mali,
and some of the poorest
countries of the world,
and think about all the wasted energy
by not harvesting the sun in
these sun-intensive venues.
And why can't we have a global campaign,
not to mention COVID vaccine,
but to mention solar
panels in high sun zones.
This is cherry picking
something that would be
relatively straightforward,
'cause fewer solar panels
would be more efficient
in high sun regions.
But even in low sun regions,
even in a cloudy day,
you can harvest energy from a solar panel.
Now I was personally disappointed
with the Biden administration decision
because I'm at the point in
my awareness of this problem
that I feel that we can't be
compromising at every turn.
If we say that federal lands
are not gonna be used
for oil exploitation,
then we stick to it.
And if we have a problem
with gasoline prices
being too high,
we look the people in the eye
on television, and we say,
"Do you have a bus that goes
from your home home to
your work or a train?
Could you call a neighbor?
Can you cut your gasoline
prices by carpooling?
What can you do to help the
Ukrainian people at this time
without sacrificing our
grandchildren's future
in a warm world?
And why can't we call
on the American people
for a war time response and draw on us
for inconvenience ourselves
and reducing our dependence
on oil by conservation?"
That's what I would've liked
to hear from the White House,
not, "Okay, we'll open up
180,000 acres of land,"
I forget how much it was,
"for oil exploitation,"
which we're not even gonna get that oil
for two, three years.
So to me, that was a very
cynical bid to win votes.
I hate to say it, that's what I think.
- [Ann] Always says what he thinks.
(indistinct)
- [Audience Member] Had a question.
While you made some of the resolutions
could be moving more
towards electric costs.
And my question (indistinct),
what are your thoughts
on the school of thought
that say that moving toward electric,
usually produces batteries,
which also produce waste,
and also increases the
demand for certain ships
that are needed for these
kind of electric cars,
mainly are mined from the, (indistinct)
which also has been made with some form
of child labor violations.
So what are your thoughts
regarding the reconciliation,
because now moving towards electric,
some people may see it more
like any other privilege,
and also (indistinct)
more electric battery
waste that in the long run,
it kind of what thoughts had been that
it kind reflected back to
these lower income countries
that already are buried in the branch
of like the first hand (indistinct).
How do you tackle (indistinct)?
- Very legitimate and important point.
I have been to many oil-rich countries
in Africa in particular,
and I've seen vast income
with very little benefit
to the people, Angola, Gabon, Nigeria.
I've seen vast exploitation
of humans in the oil industry,
and I've also seen a
tremendous pollution impact
in these settings.
So I'm not saying that
we don't have a problem
with rare earths and minerals
that are required for nickel and the like
in battery production.
Congo is one of the major producers.
China is another one
of the major producers.
So I think, yes, we have
a problem in consumption
of products that are often yielded
from an environment like Russia,
which now uses its oil money
to wage war on the Ukrainians.
So there is a challenge on
both sides of the equation
on the battery power
needed for electric cars
and for the oil and gas needed
for the fossil fuel consuming cars.
So I think one would need
a more complex analysis,
shall we say, of overall harms.
Now, can we demand that
Tesla and GM and Ford
source their materials the
way that we've tried to demand
that global diamond manufacturers
source their materials.
The blood diamonds are not permitted
and they have to be tracked, et cetera.
So there may be mitigating elements
that we can do in the
sourcing of these materials
so we don't have the choice
between abusing Congolese children
and climate change-related catastrophe
50 years from now.
So I think we have to resolve,
I have to recognize them as you have done,
address them, and resolve them.
And that would be my
choice rather than say,
"Eh, forget electric, we'll
go with the gas stuff,
'cause it won't hurt Congolese children."
Well, it's gonna hurt Nigerian children,
it's gonna hurt Gabonese
children and Angola children.
So I'm not saying it's a wash
'cause I'm not expert enough
in the topic to comment,
but that would be the way
I would think about it.
Thank you.
- [Ann] Well, I would like
now to do the other part
of this annual tradition,
which is the wizard tea,
I'm gonna invite all of
you at the reception,
and the tea for first 10, no red meat.
(indistinct) In school,
we try not to use red meat
in what we offer.
And I wanna also thank,
of course Niamh Emerson,
Lauren Langford, Olivia, and Julissa,
and everyone who I put
this together today.
- Thank you.
- And most of all we wanna thank Sten.
(audience applauding)
Because of the movies, they're
a little too big to email,
but they're on box sent to Ann's office
and they're on this computer.
Anybody who can use any of
these slides for any purpose,
please do, thank you.